Estás siendo inarticulado ...
la forma correcta es decir "Qué hay de bueno"
Ahora puedes pensar que es demasiado barrio, que eso no está bien
Estoy aquí para decirte que nuestro lenguaje tiene reglas
Así que cuando mamá se burla de mí y dice:
"te-enojarás-yendo-a-la-tienda"
Digo: "Mami, no, esa frase no sigue la ley
La palabra "Mad" nunca debe ir antes de un participio presente
Es el principio de este Inglés"
Si tuviera la capacidad vocal
cantaría esto desde cada cima de montaña,
De todos los suburbios, y cada barrio
Porque el único Dios del lenguaje es el registrado en el Génesis
De este mundo diciendo "es bueno"
Así que no siempre puedo venir ante ti
con excelencia de palabra
Pero no me juzgues por mi lengua y asumas
que soy muy ignorante para enseñar
Porque yo hablo tres lenguas
Una para cada uno:
Hogar, escuela y amigos
Soy una oradora trilingüe
A veces soy coherente con mi lengua ahora
Lo encenderé para no aburrir después
A veces me peleo entre dos lenguas
Mientras que uso la otra en mis clases
Y cuando por error las mezclo
Me siento loca como... estar cocinando en el baño
Sabía que tenía que pedir prestado tu idioma
porque los míos fueron robados
Pero no puedes esperar que hable de toda tu historia
mientras la mía está rota
Estas palabras son habladas
Por alguien que está simplemente harto de
los ideales Eurocéntricos de esta temporada
Y la razón por la que habla una versión compuesta de tu idioma
Se debe a que los míos fueron secuestrados junto con mi historia
Hablo inglés roto por lo que los cortes pueden recordarnos
Que nuestro estado actual no es un misterio
Estoy cansada de las imágenes negativas que están enloqueciendo a mi gente
Así que a menos que me hayas visto robar un banco deja de llamar malo a mi pelo
Estoy tan harta de esta disparidad racial sin sentido
No lo llamen bueno a menos que tu pelo sea conocido
por donar para caridad
Por mucho que haya sido raptada lejos de nuestro pueblo
¿Cómo puedes esperar que trate su huella en tu idioma
como nada menos que igual?
Que no haya confusión
Que no haya ninguna duda
Esto no es una promoción de la ignorancia
Esta es una celebración lingüística
Por eso puse "trilingüe" en mi última solicitud de empleo
Puedo ayudar a diversificar su mercado de consumo
es todo lo que quería que supieran
Y cuando me llamen a la entrevista
Estaré más que feliz de mostrar que
Puedo decir:
"¿Qué hay de bueno?"
"Qué pasa?"
Y por supuesto ... "Hola"
Porque soy "articulada"
Gracias.
(Aplausos)